joining us here in the Rich Eisen show
he's Kyle Rudolph how you been Kyle I'm
doing well rich how are you I am doing
well so paint me the picture what's
going on there in Vikings camp just
wrapped up
ot a number three so it's always good to
be back out on the field the way the CBA
is structured you know obviously we have
to kind of grind through about five
weeks before we can actually get back
out on the field and practice against
the defense so some new faces out here
in Minnesota this year obviously the
quarterback offensive coordinator
bringing the two biggest ones so for us
as an offense it's been a fun challenge
learning a new offense getting
comfortable one another and then going
against the best defense in football
well how different how different is the
offense come oh you know there's
obviously a lot of carryover with any
new system but you know any time you
learn a new offense a lot of the time
it's just terminology I like to explain
to people you know you're almost just
learning a new language there's a lot of
carryover in terms of concepts and play
calls it's just a matter of dialing in
on the terminology and now us
communicating that with one another so
what's your communication levels so far
with Kirk Cousins as you can tell Kyle
it's been good obviously when you add a
guy like that it gives your offense a
boost and we're excited to have him here
and I look forward to working with Kirk
in 2018 so when did you first have
contact with him the first time I got
together with him was when he came out
here for his free agency visit I was at
dinner when Kirk and his wife Julie came
in town and me and my wife Jordan were
able to sit in and enjoy dinner with he
and his wife now was that the one where
he couldn't eat certain things is that
rumor that i--dude they had to be like a
special diet dinner Kyle were you at
that one is that a true one I would not
know we're at Capital Grille and I mean
we pretty much did everything that
they've brought out okay just want to
make sure cuz yeah I thought there was
one of those things all right so we
think we were at that Capital Grille at
the Super Bowl last year I think we
stayed I know where that one is
so the concept that you've got to be
better than just a seven nothing lead in
the NFC Championship game this year
other than otherwise the the change at
quarterback
and all of the momentum of this team is
for naught what do you say to something
like that Kyle you know well for us
obviously we came up a little bit short
last year but I think one of the biggest
things that we've had to focus on this
offseason and one of the biggest points
that Coach Zimmer has tried to drive
home each and every day is we don't get
to pick off pick up where we left off in
the NFC Championship game we have to
earn each and every win this season and
right now we have Phil wins so it's
about laying a foundation for 2018
and making sure that you know when we
break for summer that we've laid a
foundation to hit the ground running in
training camp
what is Co a plane for Zimmer like Kyle
it's awesome I've had the good fortune
to play for a lot of really good head
coaches in my career and you know Kojima
is one that you know people will say all
the time I would run through a wall for
this person and you know you kind of
take it with a grain of salt but when I
say that about coach Zimmer it's it's
true because you would do it as if there
was something on the other side that you
had to have you know you wouldn't just
run through the wall because he said so
you know you truly believe that he has
your best interest in mind yeah I work
with Michael Irvin Deion Sanders they
know him from his Dallas days and they
would say all the time when he was
looking for a job or when he was not
looking for one when he was interviewing
for a head coaching job and got passed
over over and over again that people
were missing out and that they said the
same they said the same exact thing
called it they would run through a wall
for the guy and I'm wondering if there's
a specific example that you could give
to the to the fan base here to the
listeners and viewers of the show as to
when that moment you realize that with
with coach Zimmer well I think just one
of the biggest things obviously I'm from
Cincinnati so I had a little bit of
background information from personally
came up here from the bangles it just
everyone in the city of Cincinnati was
so disappointed that they were losing
coach Zimmer and then when he got here
and I had an opportunity to play for him
for two years
he just you know like I said it seems
like he always had your best interests
of mine now he's gonna be the first one
to to call you out when you do something
wrong but at the same time you know when
you buy into his philosophy and do
things the way that he wants it
John he didn't be the first one to pat
you on the back as well Kyle Rudolph
Vikings tied in here on the Rich Eisen
show so you're from Ohio how did you
wind up at Notre Dame
Kyle how did they let you out of the
state oh well when I was coming out of
high school the Buckeyes really didn't
use tight ends a whole lot they were
kind of just like a third tackle and I
wanted to run around and catch a bunch
of balls mmm
so did they not recruit you they did I
actually I went to one of my visits was
the Ohio State Michigan game when I was
one verse - mm-hmm
back to choice good year so I visited
they offered like I said I just I wanted
to go somewhere where I'd be used a
little bit more like a receiver and less
like a tackle so that Troy Smith game
where Michigan had all the momentum that
there was an awful 15 yard
unsportsmanlike conduct penalty called
on Michigan that changed the entire
moment in the game that's the game that
you were at cow that wasn't it I'm sure
that's not putting any salt and wounds
from a no that's okay
no it's just I'm used to the Big Ten
refereeing is essentially what I'm
saying you know are you ready for the
renewing of said acquaintances yes this
coming up very excited that was for me
having the opportunity to play against
Michigan ever here was one of the games
that I always looked forward to just a
history in tradition that both schools
have and you know kind of the you know
mutual respect if you would you know a
lot of times and rivalry games it's you
know this school hates this school ie
Ohio State Michigan and I don't think
that's the case in learning Michigan
it's more of a mutual respect for one
another and I'm glad to see that series
back ain't go on again you know what
Kyle I would travel the high road with
you right now but I just can't I just
can't I was going to point out you know
despite all that mutual affection for
one another
Notre Dame was the one that did walk
away from the series but that's number
one
I'm also the type of guy that rents Rudy
hoping he pops a quad towards the end
Kyle I gotta be honest with you well you
know that money talks and when they got
that big ACC contract they had to do
what they had to do
with the conference could you spit in
truth I like it so while we're on the
subject is is Rudy real is Rudy real cow
let's get that let's get that out there
you know fur for a guy who spent three
years at Notre Dame and obviously I grew
up watching Rudy
there are I you know I have a ton of
respect for Rudy and what he did that's
awesome but there are so many cases I
feel like I went to school with like
three movies you know guys that I can
remember playing with a first name that
comes my by Canelo the guy is a
undersized walk-on from Chicago just
outside of Chicago dreamed was playing
and their name walks on kills it on
special teams you know he was actually a
guy that played and contributed for us
you know another one that Joe Smith the
linebacker that was there forever
original walk-on gets a scholarship so
the Rudy story is great obviously as a
Notre Dame guy I love that story I just
feel like that there are many more
Rudy stories since then and you know
those guys have busted their tail to put
themselves in situations that you know
Hollywood is one thing but they've kind
of exceeded Hollywood well you are
trying see you are you are traveling the
high road so so much I might eat an
oxygen mask right now Kyle I mean this
is but you're also shown why you're the
Walter Payton Man of the Year nominee
and the community man of the year
they're in Minnesota so before I let you
go I do have to ask you based on all the
news that is happening with the NFL and
with the new policy that has been put
into place for the national anthem how
that has was sitting how has that been
sitting in your locker room over the
last 24 I think you know for us it's
nothing really changes because last year
we had guys on our team who had an issue
with the way things were going in
society and I think as a locker room we
support each and every one of our
teammates and what they may be going
through off the field but we felt like
as a team that was best to do one thing
and you know for us it was
standing united linking arms with every
player every coach our front office our
owners we were standing because of the
respect that we have for the flag and
what the national anthem means yet we
were still supporting each and every one
of our teammates and what they may be
going through
well art Rooney of the Steelers was
asked yesterday coming out of the
meeting and this is still a policy that
that that has some potentially devilish
details for the lack of better phrase to
be figured out details to be figured out
that linking arms might be construed as
disrespectful to the anthem and the flag
so is that something that the Vikings
are still planning on doing he's linking
I think it was necessarily something
that you know obviously we planned on it
for a few weeks it wasn't something that
we continued to do each and every week
but you know like I said I think it's
something that will handle internally as
a team but the main kind of point there
is that you know no matter what we're
going we're gonna do it as a team and as
an organization that's just the kind of
way things are run around here alright
and in that regard just last one for you
on this there have been reports that
some players are outraged at this at
this new policy and that are thinking of
demonstrating in some form of
demonstration just because of the policy
is that a conversation happening in your
locker room best you can tell no it has
not like I said the anthem issue really
hasn't been much of a discussion here
since we since it was brought up last
year during the time when it was kind of
most prevalent and like I said we
decided that no matter what we're gonna
do and do it as and then really it's
kind of gone by the wayside for us and
then just because I you know I I do this
all the time whenever I have an NFL
player or any athlete on this show and
certainly because I want to put you know
money where my mouth is the fact that
this policy is in many ways
overshadowing so many good works that
players are doing on these subjects
already or attempting to change by going
out in the community themselves
many times it overshadows even those who
have just a a day-to-day charitable
aspect I want you to do whatever
whatever is going on in your charity
life do you want to drop a website here
or way people can get involved what are
you up to
Kyle so we do most of our work with the
University of Minnesota Masonic
Children's Hospital and for those of the
listeners that don't know my background
my younger brother was born with Neil
blastoma and spent about the first year
of his life in Cincinnati Children's
Hospital so Children's Hospital's are
something that you know my family now my
wife and I and our family have always
been very passionate about we just try
to do as much work as we can at the
University of Minnesota Masonic
Children's Hospital to make the lives
and the visit of the patients and their
families just a little bit better so you
know we've started an end zone there pal
Rudolph's end zone is a space that's
just under 3,000 square feet where these
patients and their families can you know
escape the day-to-day routine of being
stuck in their hospital room and go down
and just be kids you know these kids are
not able to be at school and be out on
recess with all their friends so we just
wanted to kind of create a space tour
they could go down there and forget the
real reason why they're in the hospital
and just really be kids this is their
website somebody could go to for the
hospital for your foundation or
something that they can contribute if
should they we don't have a foundation
hope you contacted the University of
Minnesota Masonic Children's Hospital
and asked about Kyrie office endzone
they'd be able to point you in the right
direction awesome call you the man I
appreciate the time encourage em we'll
check how about we chat towards the
middle of training camp just a couple
weeks before the renewing of
acquaintances I would love yourself Bend
how about that that would sound great
all right I'm gonna call you
we'll check I'm good okay you got it me
too that's collar off the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience